[Applause]
[Music]
well trey young had a chance to maybe
put it away
shot clock is off philadelphia with the
ball they just used their last timeout
doc rivers does still have a challenge
hawks with two timeouts remaining talk
us through this philadelphia possession
here jimmy
it's real simple see if you can get a
quick two quick two you set your defense
see if you can get a steal on the
inbounds pass if not quick foul now if
you can dribble drive get
the defense to suck in and you get an
open three-point shot then you take it
but the key is get the ball in cleanly
get a quick basket the sixers have
missed their last seven field goal
attempts
no made field goals since the 6 24 mark
that was curry flop ticks here we go
harris looking for help
this is down three and that's gonna be a
block inside
on the hawks
so galinari picks up the foul
number four embiid will go to the line
[Music]
[Applause]
indeed actually i still think this play
took a little bit too much time maybe a
couple seconds
two to three seconds too long
[Applause]
atlanta with two timeouts remaining
and if he misses the free throw this is
unreal
a complete fourth quarter collapse
by the 76ers embiid stuck on 37 points
he last scored at the 701 mark of this
fourth quarter
to make it a two-point game he missed
both of them
heard him with a rebound gets the
timeout joel embiid
misses both free throws atlanta ball
up three ten and change left
[Applause]
immediately
foreign
[Applause]
ernie thank you very much looking
forward to that one this one has taken
an incredible turn now it's atlanta
with the ball up three 10.2 seconds
remaining
and there's some debris on the floor
the atlanta hawks have outscored
philadelphia
46 to 19 in the last
14 minutes so going back two minutes
left in the third quarter
currently on a 13-0 run remember joel
embiid had made 20 consecutive free
throws just missed two in a row
billy get a quick foul here
no fouls to give at this point trying to
get atlanta to the line as quick as they
can hope for some missed free throws
so here we go herder will put it in
and young in the backcourt wow dangerous
pass nivel falls down
and young is fouled
if fibo keeps his footing that's a steal
no doubt well that was an ill-advised
pass
by kevin herter young's gonna go to the
line
and herder has to understand if you
can't get it in i believe you still have
one timeout left
you can't get it in don't force it over
the top
take your four count can't get it in
call to timeout
[Applause]
to extend a run for atlanta
and make it a two possession game and
trey young
puts him up four it's a 14-0 run for the
hawks to the finish line
[Applause]
[Music]
doc rivers used his last timeout a
moment ago
cannot advance it and the reality
setting in now
for these sixers fans who saw their team
dominate this game through three
quarters
[Applause]
this series going back to atlanta
night it'll be a game six
at state farm arena that place was
rocking
monday night and a comeback win
for atlanta in that one to even up this
series
young knocks them both down he's got 39.
it's a five-point game philadelphia has
got to go fast
pork mozz got a man in the air he missed
it clock ticks curry
that one's good point one on the clock
and this is gonna be an atlanta
victory in game five what a comeback
and what a collapse by the sixers
[Applause]
109 106. the atlanta hawks now
lead 3-2 in this best of seven
second round playoff series incredible
jimmy
let's set it into the third quarter a
little momentum
get some stops knock in some shots the
three-point line will get you back in
the game
coupled with the fact that the second
unit
for the sixers didn't hold up to the
their end of the bargain
allowed momentum to slip over
[Applause]
hawks able to take advantage of it
all right let's